my name is elizabeth
i'm 18 years old
and i'm a second year university student
in dublin
and i would like to share a glimpse into
my beginnings prior to my birth
my mother
who was born in a muslim family
converted to christianity
and she faced persecution from her
family who were all muslims at the time
and fled nigeria to escape religious
persecution
and to fight for a better life for my
four siblings and i of which i am the
youngest
she tried to get asylum in a number of
countries and eventually got a lot of
acceptance from a relatively small
country known as ireland
ireland accepted her application
and while her case was pending we were
giving housing
in a small town in the west of ireland
called clifton
in one of the country's direct revision
centers
and so began the wait for my arrival
my due date was july 13th which was also
the day that my father was born
but i refused
and decided that i preferred to be born
on the 16th
and so
i was born in my mother's room
with the umbilical cord wrapped around
my neck
i was actually believed to be the first
child to be born in clifton
as opposed to in the hospital
in 15 years
i even read the local news
i guess persistence and stubbornness
pays off
and my mom still has a newspaper
that detailed my rival story
till this day
so you could say i had a rocky start to
life
other than the fact that i was born on
the floor
i was literally born into a system
that has been
criticized by human rights organizations
as a legal inhumane and degrading
but i've denied my beginnings the
ability to dictate my end
after i was born my siblings were
granted residence here
and it was a relief for her to have all
of her children with her
but what she didn't have was
her husband my father
her biggest support
in the journey
and now after 18 years
multiple rejected visa applications
countless trips to the immigration
offices and
hundreds of visits to various different
lawyers and solicitors my father has yet
to be granted access to doing his family
here
and growing up without him
has been the hardest part
so
the topic of this talk today is the need
for family reunification
and the effects of one parent households
on children
we often spend time talking about how
children are the future
and how it's necessary and crucial for
us to lay good foundations for them so
they have equal opportunities to succeed
but the first and most important
foundations in a child's life are laid
at home
within the family structure and think
about it when you have two parents who
want to be in your life having both
parents around and involved means having
access to more of the economic and
community resources available
as both parents are willing to invest
their time energy and money into the
well-being of their children
and so
i often imagine
how different life would be
if my father was here
if my father was here i would have never
had to witness my mother
painstakingly
try her best
to raise my two sisters and i along with
my two brothers alone
there is not one day
i have not heard her beg god for the
strength to raise us her earnest prayers
have been the backdrop of my sleep
and my only lullaby
for as long as i can remember
she's only one person
so she needed his strength to be in five
places at once as my siblings and i all
had our different issues and problems to
deal with that we needed her there for
but all the while struggling to maintain
a good relationship with my father who
is thousands of miles away
or what it would have meant to see my
father my recitals or my brother's
matches
none of us
would have ever been left staring into a
crowd of parents
disappointed
that our own parents our biggest
supporters couldn't be there
and i'm certain
we would have escaped experiencing
homelessness if my father was here
for months my family and i were homeless
finding housing in ireland is difficult
enough already but
just imagine how challenging it is
for a single mother
trying desperately to provide for her
five children
in fact at times it's
virtually impossible
which is how my family and i ended up
homeless
and i remember the first night we spent
at the emergency accommodation hostel
my mother siblings and i
all gathered to pray because we knew
that
the only thing we had left to depend on
was god and his mercy
it was a
tear-filled night
and we had many more of those in the
following seven months
of our homelessness
and i could give you all of the
statistics about family separation
around the world
or the harm it does children
when they have parents who want to be
together raising them but i deny the
chance to do so
but we don't need statistics or case
studies to justify the need for family
reunification because the idea that
families should be together deserve to
be together
is a fundamental human right
it doesn't arise from research evidence
or government charts
the right to be with your family
to be loved and cared for by your family
exists because you exist
it is the right of all humans
and according to the united nations
convention of the rights of the child
article 9 states that children must not
be separated from their parents against
their will
unless it is in their best interest
and children whose parents are separated
have the right to stay in contact with
them
unless this could cause them harm
and we don't have to document that harm
to show its magnitude and for those
rights to be vital and sensual and
urgent
even though of course those harms are
indeed
very real
i remember a time
when i was about seven years old
and i had been tucked into bed
by my
mom and i had a sudden realization
that i couldn't remember
what my father even looked like anymore
i began to cry to her
as it felt like the ways of time
had wiped away his image
from my mind
my memories of him
consisted of pictures and heard stories
of him
for the longest time
and now that my siblings and i are
all grown up
i hear him lamenting to my mother over
the phone
about just how much he's missed out on
it deeply pains him
that he doesn't know life with his
daughters as women
and his sons as men
and each day my yearnings grow stronger
to enjoy life with him
now that he's getting older
and for him to enjoy the fruits of his
labor
he was never given the chance to
hold my hand as i took my first steps
but i pray get the chance to hold his
when he needs my help to walk
in his old age
as many of you already know
the issue of family reunification is
more than just an irish issue
it's indeed a global issue
and it has been highlighted
by the recent takeover in afghanistan
and the ongoing israeli-palestinian
conflict
the sheer amount of families have been
displaced and the thousands of
unaccompanied children arriving on the
shores of countries all over the world
ireland included
if there are parents
who want to be together raising their
children
no government should ever stand in their
way
but should instead find ways to reunite
families have been broken up by war
persecution immigration and all sorts
but still
have a desire
to be together we need governments to
take into account the stories of young
people like myself
whose families have been needlessly
separated
by expanding safe and legal pathways for
families to migrate together whether
that be migrant workers and their
children or refugees
families have a greater chance of
staying unified
we need governments to accelerate
reunification applications
and we need them to address the
bureaucratic and political barriers to
unification for families
all over the world
my father
is a gentle loving man
and the role model i have always needed
he is a man of great integrity
and a passionate loyal advocate for the
welfare of his family
his love doesn't announce itself when it
enters into a room
it's a quiet type of love
but it knows no bounds for his family
so
i cannot possibly
begin to express
how devastating it would be
to continue living life this way
especially when i know that my father
loves me
and wants to be in my life
i want my father to join me here
in ireland
the country that my family and i are
proud
to call home
and i want all families
to be made whole
to be reunified
to be together
as is
our
right thank you